yeah well i've gotten a licking and
immediately when your tongue hits your
dick you go what am i doing
[Music]
hey hey mark norman here back on
answering questions for the uh
anal what is it answer the internet
sorry hey mark norman here back on
answer the internet
queef it up i'm gay watch out to lunch
we're almost at seven million views i
bombed the last time i was here so
hopefully i can pick it up
if you were taken hostage five years ago
what would surprise you
most about the world today ah that's
good
uh well i would be shocked that
everybody
hates ellen that would be weird like
what this dancing lesbian we all hate
her now what the hell
i'm telling you over compensation if
you're dancing
you're a [ __ ] put that on a t-shirt
if you had to win a game show to stay
alive which game show would you choose
family feud all day steve harvey stinks
i would just say a horrible couple dick
jokes to uh
to make his eyeballs go big that's his
only move
joke and steve don't uh this will set
you up though they're like
uh you know what's the number one thing
that right a girl would put inside
herself you say penis and he's like
oh
yeah come on you got one move steve i
love you though
uh but yeah i'd go family feud i kick
ass at that game and if you say
a horrible answer your family goes good
answer good answer so
it'd be the only time my family
supported me so uh i'm going big ff
fast money would you rather have a dog
die
every time you laugh or have there be a
genocide every time you fall in love
well let's see i've never made a dog
laugh it hurts my feelings
i'm very insecure i will say any dog
i've ever met
very alarmingly okay with the n-word
they don't care at all dogs will you can
say anything about jews or asians dogs
are on board
they won't cancel they'll lick your
balls if you put peanut butter on it
so uh i think i'll have the dog laugh
genocide come on there it's happening
anyway
you're you're making dogs laugh it's
every time you laugh a dog dies
wait wait wait would you rather have a
dog die oh my god
no dogs with laughter or killing a
massive amount of humans with love ah
god
i've only been loving twice so you would
have wiped out like two ethnicities by
now
oh yeah that's pretty good but how many
times have you left millions so you've
killed millions of dogs
all right we're gonna kill the somalians
i can't believe this question about
making dogs is there any athlete you
would be okay with your girlfriend
[ __ ]
let's see maybe tiger woods
well he's he's a half black half asian
you know he'd be good at it and uh you
know
he'll probably crash into a tree
eventually so
then i'll get some love i gotta go hey
sure he drove into a tree but he [ __ ]
my girl what a piece of [ __ ] so i could
always make fun of him or i'd go with
the uh
the black [ __ ] you got around here
because that would be fun yeah
i would watch that if you got ten
thousand dollars a day for every day you
didn't masturbate
how many days could you last whoa good
question
i think uh if i'm getting 10 g's a day i
think i can hold out pretty long i went
on a family trip with my parents once
for like a week and a half and i
couldn't rub one out because my mom and
me slept in the same bed
but uh yeah i can go pretty long without
jerking
i'd give it i'd give it a week and a
half so that's what that's like uh
60 grand bathrooms exist and showers and
stuff no
i don't know my mom was outside the door
clipping her toenails and i could hear
my dad
singing uh opera so i i i don't know
if i do jerk off to that that would be
even weirder so you can get 10 days
i think i get 10 days how to lose how to
lose a nut in 10 days which is a great
kate hudson movie who is the hottest
celebrity you'd have a chance with
if they got to know you i think i could
bag serena williams
yeah yeah those big thighs
nerd you know i know she's married to
the weird little honky guy which is uh
one for the uh the crackers i mean i
don't know how he pulls that
that uh that lady down
oh my god imagine those thighs jiggling
holy hell but yeah
jiggle man that's true yeah she's got
some real uh oak in her like she is
tough tough lady but i would watch that
yeah
i'll watch you and serena i think i'd
nut on her and go love
how long would it take you to eat your
own body weight in hot dogs holy hell
shout out to joey chestnut you fat loser
uh
and hiroshima whatever the asian guy's
name is he's cute
uh it's always the little guys who can
wolf down the most dogs when are we
gonna get a gay hot dog eater that would
be fun i want to see that uh
you know on the nose to be honest good
point good point
ah he would not be dipping that in water
let's see i'll go with uh
i weigh 160 about okay uh how long can i
eat my own body ah give me uh could be
two days i could do it
get hours oh yeah 3.5
ounces so 16 ounces in a pound let's go
make it even four
four dogs per pound you're eating over
500 hot dogs in two days
i mean if i map it out i get up at 7 00
a.m i have uh 200 a day i mean
are we talking bun or no bun gotta do
buns
oh wait that changes everything if
you're doing buns give me
10 days and you don't jerk off yeah
that's also what killed ralphie may
would you watch a porn with the hottest
girl from your high school if the dude
in it was your
dad not even a question
i would put that on the big screen and
i've seen my dad naked he's got a great
hog
i've urinated with my dad many times we
used to sword fight
i had a dagger it wasn't pretty he would
sometimes put his johnson over my
shoulder just to urinate
in front of me uh so my dad slept nude
i've seen his ball back
more times than i've seen the
schindler's list and
uh yeah so definitely definitely watch
my dad reel a hot uh the hottest gal in
high school what are you kidding me is
he really packing
oh my god i think i got my mom's [ __ ]
here i don't know what happened to me
but uh man my dad and my brother by the
way
no yeah i mean i'm not saying i'm small
but compared to these guys they see that
that palm tree right there is my dad
and it's very dark too it's like a
cappuccino color
um my dick's pink like a pig's nose
oh yeah oh you're one of those the
multi-color you got an obama
hey if you had the flexibility to blow
yourself would you do it
what if everybody knew you did i have
tried and i got a lick in
and say last week
but no i mean i i think we've all every
guy in here tried to blow himself right
how do you how did you try i just you
know got on the bed and went for it
wait no that's my question how did you i
was on my back and just
really uh pretzeled yeah well i've
gotten a licking and immediately when
your tongue hits your dick you go
what am i doing it's like a your mind
opens up you think clearly
it's a bad news every guy's like i wish
i could suck my dick you don't wish
right one time i filmed myself jerking
off to see what it looked like and i
painted my nails red
so it looked like a girl i just had like
a frame right here
and i was like oh this is gonna be so
hot and i watched and i was like i have
to destroy this tape
this is unbelievably sad what am i doing
with my life i was like 28.
so uh yeah it's it's a pipe dream no pun
intended but you think you want it you
don't want it
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blind child who has the greatest
voice of our generation
are you killing the kid of course i'm
killing the kid
and how easy would that be to kill a
blind kid you know he's like hey come on
put him up and then he walks right past
you shoot him in the head
come on and what's he doing the blind
kid he's not gonna
create a generation now what does that
mean singing yes oh
we got american idol we got all the i've
seen guys on the corner who are sing
better than this blind [ __ ]
would you be celibate for a year to be
able to have sex with any girl you
wanted
after the year was up this is why men
and women are different
you know women be like what are you
kidding of course not but i think i
would do it
i think i would do it just for that one
taste of kathy bates
the funny thing is this is just marriage
you know
you're willing to [ __ ] the same person
forever uh
so i guess i am you know i'm getting
married so yeah
what the hell was i thinking would you
rather have a chef a masseuse
or a chauffeur for the rest of your life
oh
man that's a good one masseuse i feel
too guilty because then you go for the
happy ending it gets weird you know
you feel bad for the polynesian lady so
i'm gonna go
i'll probably go chauffeur because that
way you get a ride to the airport you
can get a ride anywhere
drunk driving that's over i'd still want
to be able to drive but i would have my
own chauffeur just when i needed them
and i would get shit-faced and get uh
blow
and do it in front of them would you
rather be an extremely good-looking
paralyzed person or a hideous
fully functioning person well i don't
want to be some kind of weirdo [ __ ]
so i'm gonna go with the uh the ugly guy
look at ugly guys are thriving i mean
elon musk looks like my [ __ ]
no we're talking like you know dude from
the goonies
oh you're an
idiot i feel like if i'm disfigured
though i get some pity points
you know i could be a comedian i'd be
the ugly guy that you're getting pity as
a paralyzed yeah but i want to be able
to wipe my own ass
yeah that's true if there was a snail
following you for the rest of your life
and if you touched it you'd die how long
would you survive still moves like a
snail
but like he has brain power he knows he
can he'll he'll snail his way to [ __ ]
laguardia and hop on a plane
really he knows where you're at so he
still moves
like a snail can i kill him but
[Music]
i think i could last a while what i
would try to do is befriend the snail
and do a podcast with him
and and now we have a dynamic i got the
snail
trying to kill me and me trying to
figure out what his deal is and then
why are you guys so slow and what's with
the shell you gotta we can call it
coming out of your shell
and uh we'd get to know the snail i
think i would try to monetize it somehow
what's the weirdest thing you've jerked
off to whoo
boy that is a good one well i'm gonna
try to put family members out because
that's been done
i mean it's pretty standard uh you know
playground
kids and uh you know your aunt but what
is the weird one
probably maybe rachel ray is that too
uh on the nose is that too specific
well you know when you're watching
something you're like i guess i'm gonna
jerk off
like you just see a lady it's uh
you know isn't that weird we all have
that i don't know if ladies have that
you know but
uh yeah i'll just be like oh the
westminster dog show this lady with the
with the poodle is looking pretty good
then you rub one out it's like he
decides for you it's like all right
i guess yeah it's his call that's why i
don't knock the guys on the subway
rubbing one out because i'm like hey i
get it you might have seen a bag lady
or a child or whatever it is so i get it
comedy hey all right we did it
all right big thanks to mark norman for
coming through answering the internet
comedy make sure you subscribe to our
channel for all sorts of other episodes
of your favorite comics and entertainers
also make sure you leave a comment who
you want to see
and click the bell notifications so that
you got notice on